40 of people with credit cards don't
know what the interest rate on their
credit card is
40 of people who carry a balance on the
credit card don't know the interest rate
the average credit card rate is 16.3
percent according to bank rate the fed
planning to raise interest rates so
credit cards should be closer to an
average of 17 by end of year the average
balance of a u.s based credit card
holder is 5 525
if you pay minimum payments it would
take you 16 years to pay off your credit
cards which means that you would owe
more than six thousand five hundred
dollars in interest now i'm not a
mathematician but if your balance is
five thousand five hundred and twenty
five dollars and it takes you 16 years
to pay it off you would end up paying
more in interest payments than in what
you actually owed for the balance not
very good we have a quote here from nick
reyes author at frequent miler miller
who says if you're carrying a balance
from month to month forget about rewards
all together there's no way you'll come
out ahead don't carry a credit card
balance
then we have this great graphic a poll
cash back is american's favorite credit
card feature 41 of us adults said cash
back is their favorite credit card
feature far and away more than those who
favor travel rewards low interest or
wide acceptance what is wild to me is
that their favorite reward is cash back
and the next most popular one is that
it's accepted in most places literally
people would rather have a card with
high cash back than it being accepted in
most places and travel perks is only
four percent of the reason why people
actually get a credit card and so how
exactly should you learn to pay off your
credit card well it's pretty simple
first you want to transfer your credit
card interest to a zero interest rate
credit card which can defer interest for
up to 21 months that is a key piece this
is get out of the interest especially
high interest rate credit
second you can consider a personal loan
which with good credit you can probably
get to be five to seven percent sofi has
that personal own product that allows
you to consolidate your credit card so
if you have a big amount of credit card
debt you can basically stop paying 16 17
on average and you can get a personal
loan wipe out the credit card debt and
then just pay the five to seven percent
on a personal loan uh type of credit or
debt again you can raise your income you
can get a second job side hustle or you
can try to negotiate a raise at work
regardless of increasing the amount of
money that you make or that you gather
one of the best things that you can do
is simply to get it to a zero interest
rate credit card or to wipe out the
credit card debt of 16 17 percent with a
personal loan that ends up actually
changing the interest rate you pay now
of course this is not financial advice
but if you listen to ted rossman the
senior industry analyst at bankrate and
creditcards.com he says don't chase cash
back if you are paying 15 to 20 in
interest save the reward chasing until
you are debt free
and so 40 of people who have credit card
debt with the average credit card that
being over 5 000
don't know what interest rate they're
paying at some point does it matter if
you know the actual number or is it more
important that you simply know that it's
a high rate compared to lower rates that
you could get elsewhere john i don't
think it necessarily matters i think
everyone should know their number on the
interest rate if you pay off your credit
card on time which i tell you to do
basically every single day then it
shouldn't matter right but the
unfortunate thing is for over 40 percent
or around 40 of people don't know what
their interest rate is and that can be a
very big deal long term but i know what
mine is and it's very very high and it's
definitely above the average yeah i i
think it matters uh because of how many
people have credit card debt i was just
looking up the numbers briefly here and
before the pandemic it was at 800
billion dollars in outstanding credit
card debt in the united states alone and
that means uh approximately 95 of adults
have a credit card and nearly half of
them 47 of us adults or about 120
million people currently have credit
card debt right so that's a massive
amount of people that have outstanding
debt so obviously the equation of kind
of how much you're going to owe relative
to your monthly balance is important in
that aspect but ultimately yeah it's
just like
i i think it's uh is it dave ramsey who
basically just says like just do
everything in cash like you never want
to have he doesn't believe in credit
cards and all these other things because
when you really think about those
numbers it seems logical to all of us
like hey make sure you pay off your
credit card you don't want to get
charged these high interest rates
whether it's 14 percent 18 20 it's
higher than you could get for a loan or
in these other things right so make sure
you pay off your credit card don't get
one if you can't do it but the stats
show something completely different
which is half the people nearly half the
amount of people uh 120 million people
here in the united states that get
credit cards do not pay off their
balance each month right so relative to
that a credit card is not a good option
for a number of people and there are
certain circumstances right where people
need uh they only get paid on the first
and the 15th and the the ability to kind
of roll that over for a 30-day
interest-free loan but if you get caught
up in that debt you don't pay it off it
can be crippling at interest rates like
that
i think that the idea behind this is
exactly what you are saying here which
is credit cards can [ __ ] you
financially and like here's like the big
warning right is that if you are not
careful and you take on this high
interest debt
then before you know it if you're not
paying it off every month uh you can get
into this spiral that ultimately ends up
taking such a long time to get out that
you again as we used in the example you
end up paying more in interest payments
than you do actually in the balance
which for the credit card company they
love yeah right they made a ton of money
they made sixty five hundred dollars in
that example uh off of the interest
versus just getting the balance paid off
which was you know five thousand dollar
balance you wanna know something crazy
it's also it's also about the buy now
pay later stuff and like financing
different uh larger purchases which
people have traditionally done with
obviously cars furniture any of like the
bigger name purchases but i know someone
who recently bought a dog this weekend
and guess what the rate is that you have
to pay on interest if you have below a
650 credit score wait wait for a dog for
for they they they brought a dog
you got a 650 or a lower credit score
finance the purchase of a dog that might
be a dog feedback as to why you got 650.
the dog calls a few thousand dollars
it's purebred i don't really know i
don't have a dog i'm not getting a dog
but what do you think the rate is for if
you blow a 650 for these for these loans
30
110 no no
that's what that's what i was telling
that's got to be illegal
that's robbery but the whole point is
don't do that somebody with a
six-year-old someone who's winning or
someone who went and bought the dog with
a 650 credits no they they're like
above the 650. they're like but think
about that don't take financial advice
from someone with 650 or below well
usually
in certain circumstances like there are
businesses that people operate that run
these right and they take money
yeah they they
some people put up their house a car or
whatever it is right if you don't have
the credit score to be able to justify
some of these loans so you can obviously
take that route obviously that's not
recommended
but ultimately i think the the
distinction between good debt and bad
debt is important also right because the
financial markets over the last decade
have been dominated by really cheap debt
right everyone has been able to access
capital if you want to make investments
you want to do these things you could
take out a mortgage at a super low
interest rate you could buy investment
properties you could borrow money to
invest and do all these things so it has
dominated good debt has been extremely
helpful for a number of people bad debt
is credit card debt where you're not
able to pay it off monthly you get hit
with these fees and you get in this
cycle where you're not able to break so
i think there's a distinction like not
all debt is bad there's there's certain
people out there that always just say
hey no debt don't take debt don't do
debt and that's not the reality right if
you use debt in the right way it can be
extremely helpful you shouldn't pay cash
for your house necessarily right if
interest rates are super low and you can
earn more money of that investing with
that capital then it makes sense to take
out a 30-year mortgage or whatever it is
and go invest that money on the side
instead so there's a distinction
obviously between good debt and bad debt
and i think when it comes to credit
cards like everyone should be in
agreement that
not paying off your credit card every
month and carrying a balance and getting
hit with 16 to 22
uh annual interest rate is not a good uh
not a good strategy long term for
financial freedom what do you guys think
uh
do most people obviously most people
prefer cash back do you guys use cash
back or do you guys use the points and
then transfer the points to travel or
cash or buy buy products with it
i personally uh like getting bitcoin
back which is the equivalent of cashback
but i've taken a different currency i
don't take it in that fiat stuff i take
it in a decentralized digital
transparent programmatic monetary policy
currency that i have uh a long-term
belief it's going to end up retaining
its value at a higher rate
than the debasement and devaluation of
the fiat currency i have a credit card
that i'm not going to advertise for this
company because uh
they're shitty
you have a shitty credit card
i mean no it's like a legit credit card
like you know it'd be one everyone knows
about but it's uh it's uh not a not one
i would go recommend to other people
because they give out rewards it's like
travel rewards so you know you get like
uh you can get cash back for trips you
take for ubers for restaurants for
flights for stuff like that uh but
ultimately yeah you're probably better
off investing or earning rewards in an
asset that can appreciate over time
rather than depreciate i also think it's
funny that probably 99 of people who
have a credit card and get points back
uh especially points but maybe even cash
back they don't really do the
calculations themselves and if the
credit card companies really wanted to
they could easily just not give you the
uh the points that you are deserved and
earned throughout the time period that
you had their credit card so it's just
interesting i think everyone should just
do a little calculation and keep the
credit cards companies honest well think
about someone who got a credit card
right take a take if you went and got a
uh a travel rewards credit card and they
paid you cash back and say say most of
these things have an offer from like 500
to a thousand dollars depending on how
much you spend within the first three
months or four months right so say you
go and did that a year ago uh and you've
been saving up for maybe a year maybe
two years whatever it is and you uh were
looking to basically save as much travel
awards as you could to take a trip right
you said hey i need a thousand dollars
two thousand dollars to take a trip so
i'm gonna keep spending on this card
whatever i typically do i'll just always
swipe the card and i'll save up enough
points to go take this trip the value of
those points has been severely
deteriorated over the last year with
inflation right just just on the basis
of how much the flight's going to cost
how much the hotel's going to cost how
much all the food and all the goods that
you're going to do on this trip and use
on this trip cost in the long run so
when you start to think about how
inflation plays into that role you're
much better off getting bitcoin or
something equivalent like that in in
return versus actual points to go used
towards a vacation because everything
that you're going to do on that vacation
and use for that vacation is going up in
price while the uh well hopefully the
asset you're buying is an investment and
also continues to appreciate
i think that the other piece of this is
how inflationary the airline or travel
miles points etc are uh if you think
that the fiat currency is uh
inflationary those are
it's like you can never have more than
like a couple thousand dollars worth of
airline amounts i got a lot of airline
miles they're never worth more than a
couple thousand yeah like it's just
somehow it always just like like it just
hit like a a a bar and it just can't go
higher right you're just stuck and like
nah we you always gonna have like 2 500
like hey man i got a lot of miles like
you get more miles but somehow i don't
get more dollar equivalent value